hello sonalika could you please confirm
if my voice is audible
[Music]
hi
yes we can see your screen and your
voice is also all right thank you so
much
so
hello everyone hello everyone
we'll be starting in five minutes
thank you for joining uh maybe in the
chat section you can please introduce
yourself
and tell us about your research
interests and your background thank you
hello everyone a very warm greeting to
one and all
i would like to welcome you all for
today's webinar on omixlogic precision
medicine summer training program
my name is srigiri krishna kumar and i'm
a research intern at find biotech i'll
be your host for today's webinar
so before proceeding further let us
discuss what this program is all about
the precision medicine program is
designed to introduce students and
researchers to the field of
bioinformatics in precision medicine
in this program we will explore how the
various omix data types generated in
these studies can be analyzed and
integrated to study the basic biology
associated with viruses and their host
cancer onset development and outcomes
this online program also includes weekly
sessions with an instructor online
tracking and a review of student
progress access to all the resources and
materials online for self-paced learning
access to expert guidance and problem
solving educational and research
pipelines domain data analysis on our
big data server for 15 days
in this webinar we will discuss about
the overview of the precision medicine
program the current applications of
bioinformatics and precision medicine we
will also
take a look at the detailed curriculum
of the program and finally we will
discuss about the registration and
certification process
so before going further what is
precision medicine the precision
medicine is an emerging approach for
disease treatment and prevention that
takes into account individual
variability in genes environment and
lifestyle for each person
this approach will allow doctors and
researchers to predict more accurately
which treatment and prevention
strategies for a particular disease will
work in which groups of people
it is in contrast to the
one-size-fits-all approach in which
disease treatment and prevention
strategies are developed for the average
person with less consideration for the
differences between individuals
after decades of research we are poised
to enter a new era of medical practice
where detailed genetic and other
molecular information about a patient's
cancer is routinely used to deploy
effective patient-specific remedies to
treat it as you're about to enter the
era of precision medicine the biology is
now seen as a field of data science
biology is rapidly acquiring the
character of data science billions of
data on genes proteins and other
molecules are compiled in large files
and systematically studied
analyzing this data will lead to more
knowledge and understanding about living
organisms including human health
biotechnology crops and livestock
this program will give an overview of
bioinformatics for students biologists
and clinicians the influx of data
associated method methodologies and
data-driven research makes
bioinformatics for life sciences as
prominent as the emergence of computers
for the tech industry
the goal of omix-logic programs are to
provide training in bioinformatics
enabling independent research guided by
mentors and clear example
developing a growing community with
shared passion for data-driven research
and appreciation of citizen science
enabling students clinicians and faculty
of all backgrounds to develop novel and
independent research using latest
technology in life and data sciences
with so much data available on any
biological topic in question
running an independent in silico
research project over the summer seems
like a great opportunity but let me ask
do you have the resources to complete
your big data analysis do you have a
mentor that can help match the right
analysis method to the research question
do you have a community to keep you
accountable and provide you with
feedback
if your answer to these questions is a
no but you are motivated to learn we are
offering a special research fellowship
program where you will be mashed with
the research mentor get access training
resources and big data analysis tools to
get you there
after completing this program you will
know how to do the following that is
read and understand bioinformatics
literature perform basic ngs data
processing steps
analyze data and form hypothesis
prepare data for machine learning
analysis cross-check signals with gene
databases know what type of data is
required to answer scientific questions
create your own bioinformatic analysis
present your results in an unorganized
way
all these skills are essential in
bioinformatics and some can be
translated to other fields as well
the omics logic portal gives students
options for analyzing a given data set
code dependent paths or code independent
paths
these data sets and associated
publications can be used in several ways
you can learn bioinformatics without any
coding at all for that in each project
we explain the analysis pipelines on the
user-friendly t-bioinfo platform for big
data analysis
you can also learn the scripts behind
many of the steps learning to wrangle
clean visualize and analyze data in
popular languages like r and python in
order to create your own analysis
finally you can hear about the projects
and the research applications in our
mentor guide programs where experts
share their experience and support
research projects developed by you
after using the tbio info platform to
visualize the pipelines and practice
analyzing students are then able to take
their theoretical knowledge and apply
that in a project
then check their comprehension with
levels and badges certificates of
completion and test similarly faculty
should be able to assign the omex logic
portal to their students with the
understanding that it will give them
holistic and comprehensive knowledge of
bioinformatics beginning with bytes and
molecules and onto designing their own
question based project
now let us start by signing up on the
learn dot omics logic portal this portal
education portal will help you to get
started on your bioinformatics journey
so i'll pause for a couple of seconds so
that everyone can
sign up on the portal or just we have
shared the link
so once you are done signing up on the
portal please let me know and i'll
proceed further
all right so once you have signed up on
the portal this is how the completed
profile would look like
in the completed profile you will have
an updated profile picture you should
also link your social media handles and
that will include either facebook
linkedin instagram or kyrie or twitter
you can also mention your educational
background and research interests so
that
community can reach out to you
the mentors are also able to track your
progress on the activity section
and help you with any technical queries
that you have
after you after you register you will be
redirected to the courses tab here you
can search for any course title use the
tags to find series of resources
around a topic or choose one of the
collections down below
in this session
we will in this video we will look at
the getting started collection
so here after completing a course you
will achieve 500 points after running a
pipeline you will gain 100 points and
updating your profile
will give you 100 points and finally
group activities can earn you 10 points
after achieving the learning outcomes
you would have learned some of the major
best practices in the field of
bioinformatics you will be exposed to rn
python two powerful programming
languages out there bioinformaticians
will need to understand how to use
t-test regression and other tests
analyzing and managing data in order to
communicate important information is
another best practice in bioinformatics
pipeline development and utilization is
another common practice ultimately
completing the precision medicine
program will help you enter the field of
bioinformatics since you will learn
several best practices
now i would like to take you all through
the sign up logic learn portal
so
here since i have already signed up on
the portal i have my email id and
password saved on the portal otherwise
you can click on create an account and
enter your name email id and choose a
password for the account
or you also have the option to sign up
using any of the social media handles
that is google facebook github or
twitter since i'm already signed in
using the
my gmail account i'm going to proceed
further
as explained uh click on the tab
that displays your email id
this will take you to uh your profile so
here you need to have
an updated profile picture your name
should be capitalized in proper manner
you have to link your social media
handles include your educational
background and your research address
all right so the next i would like to
invite mr ilya brodsky his background is
in
applied mathematics and data science
he has facilitated and managed
collaboration with researchers at
stanford ucsf louisiana state university
and other academic and pharma research
and development teams mr brodsky
oversees the strategic development of
research project and manages the team
responsible for bioinformatic analysis
training and collaborations for pine
biotech
in this part of the webinar mr elia
brodsky will be discussing about the
overview of the program
so over to you mr elia brockton
thank you very much mr gillery and
welcome everyone to this webinar
in my part of this presentation i want
to briefly introduce the topics that we
will cover in the training program to
give you a sense of what kind of
activities you will be involved in what
kind of topics you might apply
bioinformatics to and how will we
structure this program and then i'll
pass it on to
another team member to talk about the
structure of each session what is going
to be covered when how to register for
the specific program and what to expect
so
when we speak about bioinformatics
typically the background of the majority
of the people related to bioinformatics
is in research
and in research primarily the focus of
bioinformatics is to understand what is
in the data and link it to a specific
phenotype so so that we can characterize
a very defined process and find links to
the application
and then bioinformatics in medicine
has to do with taking that research and
applying it to
diagnose and treat specific diseases
and in this program we're going to focus
on several different diseases one of
them and a major cause of death in the
united states and around the world is
cancer
so
cancer was the second leading cause of
death um in the united states uh or in
the world sorry and uh primarily it
affects western nations but it is uh
affecting more and more developing
nations as well
and
the study of cancer has led us to
first of all kind of identify specific
genes that are responsible for different
aspects of cancer development and
progress and then eventually today more
and more studies focus on a much greater
detail of how the systems biology of
cancer can be used to treat and
help people even by preventing cancer
so to understand cancer progression we
need to understand that
healthy cells as they develop
eventually some of them
lose
some mechanisms of restriction
that cause
those cancers with damaged dna and all
kinds of unwanted processes to
proliferate uncontrollably and even
spread throughout the body and so when
we speak about cancer and
stages of cancer development we're
speaking about the onset of cancer when
these cells start to appear and there's
a tumor and eventually spreading
throughout the body and that is what we
call metastases
and what's important to
address this problem to really treat
cancer
a critical part of that is screening and
identifying the risky populations and
then within those risky populations to
identify the onset of cancer
and so what people have been doing to
understand these mechanisms at the
biological level is identify markers of
cancer risk
and translating those markers of cancer
risk to
strategies for screening and early
diagnosis of cancer
now a lot of that relies on modern
technologies like next generation
sequencing
and what people have found is that next
generation sequencing can allow us to
understand what happens in the cell
using the same technology but monitoring
several different critical molecular
processes inside tissues and cells
and
collectively we call these data types
generated by next generation sequencing
omics and these omics data can be
applied to different levels of
what happens
within the cell on aggregate for example
in a whole tissue or specific to an
individual cell and that's where we have
single cell technologies like single
cell genomics single cell
transcriptomics etc
and so when we
tried to understand
how these technologies can help us
detect what's happening inside the cell
one of the ways to use is to measure
transcriptomic
transcriptomic signals and those signals
are a good proxy for what we will call
as the functional component the proteins
that are being produced within the cell
here's a good example
in breast cancer
there is a specific receptor on the
surface of the cell
called per2
and
that receptor is responsible for
signaling that communicates with
inside the nucleus
how to produce
specific growth hormones and that is one
of the causes of this unproliferated
growth
well to measure proteins on the surface
is not very practical
uh and so people have used
transcriptomics to identify the gene
that expresses her2
and that gene is erbb2
and by looking both at the level of
expression and alternative splicing of
that gene
we can identify potential responders to
treatment but these kinds of strategies
focused on just a single gene have
essentially been evolving and so what we
see within different types of cancer
like for example breast cancer we are
seeing that the classification of cancer
continues to expand and it continues to
expand based on
a growing number of marker genes like
her2
and an integration between those genes
which is the molecular classification
but also multiple other factors like
even proteomics and metabolomics
and that's why we see this conversion
between
research-based bioinformatics and
clinical use
of bioinformatics where this kind of
understanding of what happens at the
molecular level is actually critical for
accurate classification of an individual
patient or a group of patients but
ultimately also for selecting a
treatment that is more likely to work
and be effective for that individual
so as a result bioinformatics for
clinical use relies on
big data of various types that is
integrated and ultimately is being used
for diagnostics and therapeutics
now what's interesting is that not only
is this data being used for patients but
essentially we are seeing
a number of experiments that are not
possible on actual human patients
and so another major challenge in these
kinds of studies is to be able to
accurately represent what happens inside
the patient's body by using animal
models of human disease and so when we
will explore the role of bioinformatics
in precision medicine and examples of
bioinformatics applied to data sets we
will use both clinical samples taken
from patients but also animal models
like
patient xenograph models where a tumor
is grafted inside the animal
to study those biological processes but
also to try and
intervene using a variety of compounds
and that essentially leads us to this
kind of big data paradigm
uh molecular studies where we have
uh kind of a a
an approach of
using data to inform our hypotheses
and essentially then being able to model
a specific process
and apply that process to actual
treatment of patients
and that leads to shorter discovery and
validation timeline
higher success rate and lower costs and
these are really the objectives of
precision medicine in terms of their
actual clinical use
because if we were just to take all of
the data available about the patients
and use that data for every single
individual it is just simply cost
prohibitive
but if this kind of collection and
analysis of data is informed by large
scale studies
that then can stratify patients and
determines which ones are likely to
benefit from this approach then it leads
to
actual improvement in
outcomes
more efficacy but also lowering costs
overall
so in this program
we will benefit from those large
studies that have collected
systematically
data about different types of projects
and so as you can see on this chart uh
the growth in the amount and
availability of data has been
exponential over the past a couple of
decades actually and today we have
access to
smaller studies and larger studies and
one of those studies related to cancer
is called the cancer genome atlas tcga
so what's unique about this study is
that they have been able to collect
systematically from different locations
and in different types of tissues and
cancers
a huge collection of thousands of
individuals
that comprehensively characterizes their
genomic transcriptomic proteomic and
even metabolomic profiles
allowing us to search through the
clinical data that are associated with
risk factors and outcomes and even
treatment
and determine how we can use this data
both at the clinical and the molecular
level to better understand this complex
disease so one of the studies that we
will look at is how such multinomics
integration and analysis of molecular
profiles has led to
a new understanding of complex diseases
based on multiple types of omics data
but the tcga project is already not so
new so i think it was started in 2013 so
it's been around for quite some time
what has happened since then
well more recently a new study called
all of us research has started making
their data accessible as well
and so there we have uh the objective is
to have over a million individuals that
represent both different kinds of
conditions but also help us understand
the variability of healthy individuals
so another source of data that we will
look at and we will try to see what
kinds of cohorts are available is the
all of us research hub and i think for
all of you that are coming from a
research background this is an exciting
new opportunity to try and understand
and develop preliminary hypotheses based
on this data about those topics that you
are interested in
another interesting project that we will
look at throughout this program is the
nih human microbiome project that
exclusively focuses on characterization
of metagenomic sequencing for human
microbiome both for for healthy
clinical and pre-clinical individuals
it's an exciting
project that has grown over the years
today we have the human microbiome
project one human microbiome project two
and the project continues to evolve with
specific focuses and actually is going
to be a part of the all of us research
as well
in addition to these large repositories
we will also look at several examples of
publications that have leveraged animal
studies or cell line studies to
accurately represent patients and test
different assumptions both about about
molecular characterization of patients
but also on testing and response to
different types of treatments both those
that are already on the market and those
that are still being evaluated in
clinical trials
now when you think about all of these
different data sets and the skills that
you might need to have to address some
of the interesting questions that you
could answer with these data sets you
might feel overwhelmed
and this is understandable because there
are so many different tools and packages
and methods including statistical
analysis machine learning and deep
learning it is difficult to envision one
to be able to go through all of that
learning from scratch about the
important questions the data sets and
all of the tools
and so for that reason what our team has
done is worked with the tower
bioinformatics research center that has
developed a user-friendly version of all
of these complex algorithms that one can
learn to use and understand the logic of
analysis without being hindered by the
technical complexity of each one of
these methods so the platform offers a
user-friendly interface on this
interface there are color-coded paths or
pipelines that you can reproduce
accurately and get easy to understand
and use visual outputs that speak to the
biology that can be found in this data
included are several different pipelines
and utilities that you can use to work
with this complex data be able to
understand and mine it and especially
we will use curated data sets that allow
us to deploy standard or conventional
machine learning techniques to explore
and understand variability defining
groups of patients or
specific gene sets that can identify
individual patients
now what we'll do is we will look at
this through the lens of case studies
and we will try to use
data from the types of
studies that i already mentioned like
cancer human microbiome project or all
of us research but we will also
incorporate some ideas from the
infectious diseases where an important
trend has emerged over the past several
pandemics or epidemics in the past
couple of decades and those include such
outbreaks like ebola virus outbreak in
west africa in 2014 2016 uh different
types of understandings of the disease
the pathogen interacting with
the host and understanding responses to
those markers but also using microbiome
and infection which will allow us to
appreciate the role of multi-omics
integration and bioinformatics in those
kinds of studies as well
so what can you expect as a result of
going through such training
the real outcome is a project not only
will you be able to listen to lectures
from experts that will highlight some
important aspects of current and
traditional development of
bioinformatics in different applications
but you will also be able to design a
project that highlights and showcases to
the world what you are able to do with
these kinds of skills
so specifically we will talk about the
application of such tools for clinical
decision making where we will look at
such applications like patient
stratification disease classification
identification of potential responders
to therapies mechanisms of disease onset
and progression
and the way that such tools are used in
both pharma and biotech early biomarker
discovery detection of toxicity at the
in vitro stage analysis of molecular
mechanisms of a drug action and drug
repurposing or repositioning
so these kinds of topics are impactful
and can be very meaningful whether you
are a student and you would like to
demonstrate what you have learned and
how you have been able to use data to
ask and answer some of these complex
questions or they could be useful for
your research where you're interested to
get into this field you would like to
improve your skills but ultimately you
would like to try and see how they work
in real life
throughout the program you will be given
access to some of the tools that i
already mentioned but we will also rely
on rstudio and biopython to analyze data
sets and write the code uh maybe simply
by modifying it or actually writing it
from scratch
and to do that our portal that uh sri
gauri already showed to you and you have
enrolled in
offers a number of
kind of guided processes to help you
understand the link behind the logic of
the analysis the syntax of the code the
different curated data set examples that
we are going to look at and
practicing that code so that you can
ultimately become independent
and as a result of this you will be able
to
accumulate a repository of your own uh
code that you can essentially use in the
future for your own research or for
whatever situation you will come across
in your future career
so here are some learning outcomes that
we envision for this program i think
that you will learn to appreciate and
understand scientific literature that
describes analysis of various types of
omnics data including genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics and others
you will know how to perform basic
processing steps for such data with
consistent accuracy you'll be able to
perform exploratory analysis and
generate a hypothesis from data
you'll know how to design contracts
contrasts for statistical tests and
prepare data for machine learning
you'll be able to annotate found signal
using biological databases and
references and you'll learn how to
identify appropriate data sets for
answering a specific biological question
as a result you will
learn and be able to plan a
bioinformatics analysis from start to
finish completely independently
and we will offer an opportunity to
present your final project proposal
including the rationale the methods
scientific background and anticipated
results to an experienced mentor that
will be able to provide you with
feedback
i'll finish with this testimonial of a
previous participant her name is olgo
dartsva and she was the research
affiliate a postdoctoral student at
roswell park comprehensive cancer center
what she said was that the program is
very well structured and easy to follow
the skills that she gained through the
program helped her significantly enhance
the relevance of her research by making
connections between the pre-clinical
study and its practical application to
cancer patients
so with that i would like to pass this
on to dr mohit mozunder who will speak
about some of the program resources the
outline of the different sessions and
all of the topics that will be covered
in those sessions
over to you mate
thank you ilya and hello everyone
i would like to share my screen first
and i would like to say hello to all of
you here who have joined this webinar
and today we would want to
uh as shri gauri introduced us
and
told us about the flow of the webinar uh
we wanted to show you an overview
followed by that uh the next segment is
to tell you more about the structure of
the program
and how the sessions will be conducted
and to answer any questions that you
have for this training so i'll start
with my introduction so my name is mohit
and i have a phd in computational
biology and over 40 publications on
various
topics research topics research problems
that i was able to collaborate and work
with different scientific groups
and in in pine biotech we are helping
students to achieve some of those
outcomes through specific sort of
training which are very targeted and
today we are going to discuss this great
opportunity to learn about a very uh
innovative incoming and very important
field of
life science which is precision medicine
and it's
a training that we have designed that is
uh that is something that you will not
be able to find elsewhere so
about the sessions the way we have
scheduled this entire program includes a
lot of resources that you can learn and
take on your own so you will have your
uh your own time uh the at which you can
learn from these resources which we will
be sharing throughout the program uh
however we will also have uh uh live
sessions uh which are like 10 live
sessions which we have scheduled for the
month of june and july where we will be
discussing about these steps several
topics and you will have an opportunity
to discuss and ask the mentors while we
go through these topics and discuss uh
several of these projects and case
studies that elia was mentioning but
before that like i think the best place
for me to show you this is the learn
page where we have put together where we
have put all of this together
so
if anyone can confirm that um
sonalika if you can confirm or elia you
can confirm if you can see my browser as
well
yeah we can see
all right perfect
so as i was thinking
this is the first orientation session
where we wanted to tell you uh take you
through the um through the program and
tell you that why we are conducting this
program what are the benefits and what
we are going to go through this in in
this entire research based uh experience
so it's very important to understand
that what will be the flow when will be
the sessions uh uh held and uh how much
access you will have for all of these
resources so we have put together this
program page on learnomicslogic and this
is the link
for this page
that you'll find in the chat
so in here we have described the
sessions with dates and the topics that
will be covered along with that very
interestingly you'll find the associated
resources hyperlinked in this page and
this is a great place to overview the
entire program because we will have the
first session on 14th of june uh which
will be the start of the program where
we will be discussing and taking you
through the specific specialized
sessions with expert but before that
like the time that you have we will
encourage you to take
the uh
take the program and start with some of
the preparatory materials that we'll be
sharing once you register so uh we will
talk about the registration uh towards
the end of this webinar we will where we
will be taking you through the
uh through the different subscription
levels that we have and the benefits
within those levels but before that
let's discuss the sessions one by one
and the resources that it associates uh
with it so the first session we are
going to start with a major problem the
cancer research problem and cancer
problem that ilia was describing in much
detail so without taking much of your
time i'll just like to tell you that we
are going to start with some of these
case studies where the uh a lot of ngs
lot of data science and lot of
other technologies are used so we have
these different examples for you to
learn from so we will be discussing
about the complexity of cancer and where
bioinformatics is used where this entire
big data is being generated how this
data is being generated and then how
what are the different ways we can
visualize this data understand what is
in there and where to look for so we
have uh also uh included some of these
project examples for you to get started
and understand and look at the overview
so if you click on some of these links
and open it in a new tab
so you'll find out that what kind of uh
material is associated with one of these
lessons so i already have a subscription
here so i've been able to go into each
of these courses and see that how a
detailed lesson is
is provided within these links
now uh after the first session where
we'll be introducing about the problem
cancer problem and
where the application is we will learn
about some of the emerging and important
technologies through which we can find
some of the interesting facts that elia
was describing
about finding specific mutations
understanding how to analyze genomic
data so the next session which was which
would be on 16th of july uh sorry june
we will be discussing about the next
generation sequencing uh method call and
application of genomics where we will be
learning about from the very beginner
level we have materials put together on
genomics so there is a course three on
omics logic that describes the
the genomics from a dna
point from a beginner level where you're
learning about dna and its structure to
the big data and like uh how to
interpret how do you map variants how do
you detect and find those small changes
which is equivalent to finding needle in
a haystack so uh the first session after
the first session and the second session
which would be on genomics we will be
going through a case study and this is a
very uh interesting case study on
oncogene variant calling and again you
can always
take
go to this page and check for yourself
these links and go to these links and
understand that what this project would
be all about and what this session will
be about and what we will be covering so
here there is an example of a new
project on
oncogene variant calling that we'll be
covering in this in this uh case study
session where we will be discussing
about like you know understanding that
how mutations and variations uh
accumulate with time and are passed on
to the progeny and then how how do you
find this prominent mutation that could
help you find answers to some of the
major problems when we are looking at a
strategic uh
strategic plan to stop or design
clinical trials for these cancer
studies so uh understanding that would
be uh understanding genomics and
understanding how genomics can be
applied and how genomics is applied in
real research so it's it's a part of a
mixed logic training that you have to go
through some of those data sets that we
have put together from high value
publications from uh from peer-reviewed
uh articles and also data sets that are
really
[Music]
are really digested well in the
community and have a translational
research outcome followed by that we
have a session on
on 23rd which describes the
transcriptomics data analysis because
when we are talking about precision
medicine we are describing that how
different types of data helps in
understanding uh
the uh how we can come up with a
solution strategy which is much
personalized and helps in finding those
answers
within small cohorts so here we are
looking at gene expression data we are
trying to understand that how do you
interpret and under and analyze gene
expression data using statistics using
uh machine learning unsupervised machine
learning so we will start understanding
about uh analyzing the transcriptomics
data using uh different uh uh algorithms
and workflows on tbi info platform as
well as applying downstream analysis
processes to visualize to understand the
nature of the data and the patterns from
the data using machine learning methods
so from here on we will be learning
about different machine learning methods
that could be utilized in understanding
and visualizing and interpreting the
data that is generated from these
experiments where we have patient
samples where we have cell line data
where we have data from mouse models and
all of these data resources is something
that are playing huge huge role in every
day's research in like cutting edge
research so
how do you find these data sets is
something that we are going to cover in
the next session which would be an
amazing session because uh understanding
how to analyze data and then finding
data kind of summarizes it all that uh
how one can go about a new research how
one can
you know develop a research question so
these five sessions are going to cover
some of the major aspects including some
of these important data repositories
such as ncbi sra ncba geo and tcga
cosmic and all of those uh
that you might also be interesting
interested of and you can also uh be a
part of this these sessions by
registering for the program and ask and
add your own you know
areas and discuss with us and so that we
can help you in uh in understanding more
uh the next session is again a case
study on modeling cancer precision
medicine
where we will be taking you through this
project uh you can obviously take take a
look at this link also so this project
tells about uh
breast cancer data again and finding
genomic mutations and understanding that
how
um how different types of responses to
treatments are integrated with uh
different types of omics data so this
will include machine learning as well as
use of omics data and integrating the
drug response so that you understand
that how this is applied in
precision medicine which is very
relevant to the program so after this uh
after the session we have a more uh a
session which is more focused towards
clinical diagnosis because we are
talking about precision medicine so we
are talking about different types of um
challenges that uh
that the world is facing which includes
you know multi-drug resistance which
includes
finding uh
stage specific uh
interventions uh and all of that so
we'll be learning about different case
studies here uh we will be learning
about you know how viruses and how
bacterias how pathogens are also
causing some of the major diseases which
we were not able to correlate before
without the analysis of big data but
with the help of big data and different
types of big data we've been able to
analyze and correlate and understand
that how this plays a role in clinical
diagnosis now um as as we were
discussing before and we went through
this entire
overview by elia brodsky where we
learned about that not only cancer but a
lot of uh analysis and especially after
the covet outbreak has been done for
infectious disease research where
precision medicine is playing a vital
role so from cancer we will move to
another important aspect of you know
human health which is infectious
diseases here we will learn about host
response to viral infection then we will
learn about uh the kovid 19 case study
that we have put together so there is
also a
project that we will be discussing in
this session and you can also check this
co a project two that we have on kovit
uh which is available on learn portal
where we will be discussing about
uh as we discussed also like how this
hap how this affects the host and also
what are the different uh
transcriptional signature when we have a
treatment so understanding from a drug
response level to understanding how the
at a genomic level this plays a role
when we are looking at the genome of the
virus itself
so uh i mean very exciting sessions that
we have put together so after july 14th
we have july 19th which is like the
final session where we are going to
discuss how all of this information
makes sense for you to work on your own
project uh different case studies
putting together uh a logic from you
know developing from introduction to
developing a research question and
finding results and then you know
validating it and
trying to
work on a research project so
advancements in precision medicines
areas and opportunities and
also like this includes the
opportunities that are there um with uh
with which we are sharing regularly on
our social media handles so um this is
what we have put together for
you to learn in this summer program
which is bioinformatics for precision
medicine and
i'll be happy to answer any of questions
so far if you have uh
about the schedule about the sessions
about the timing about the time
commitment that you would need to you
know go through all of this so um please
feel free to ask your questions in the
chat and i'll be happy to uh answer
those next we will be taking you through
the registration process and telling you
what different subscription models that
we have that actually helps every every
individual participant to get this
personalized experience in for
learning
precision medicine and application of
bioinformatics and german
thank you so much dr mohamed
and we have a question by abdul
are these all lectures or the really yes
they will definitely include hands-on
practical sessions as well
along with the lectures
so uh the program page that dr mohamed
just went through and explained each and
every session uh sessions topics
in the program page itself we have
listed the practical sessions as well
that is supposed to go along with the
lecture series
[Music]
all right so i'll just take you through
the program resources and then we'll
discuss about the registration so hold
on there are a couple more questions uh
so like a couple more questions
so uh galivity is asking is it suitable
for computer science research scholar
and pragna how much time do we need to
dedicate per week so maybe you can
answer those questions
yes um sure
so for a computer science research
scholar i think we have already students
who have come from computer science
background and
are part of the program so uh for
those who are from computer science
background we do understand that they
need a
overview of biology and overview of
application of these biological data
analysis so we have prepared the
asynchronous coursework um
galivetti
which describes which helps you i mean
to understand some of those basic
concepts so that you can learn and apply
meaningful and do meaningful research in
this space so i think yes i think if if
you are thinking about doing some of
these omix logic training programs i
think we will be able to help you um do
go through the training
um the second question is i see is from
pragna how much time do we need to
dedicate per week so per week we have uh
two sessions
and the sessions are usually for 60
minutes to 90 minutes which includes
like overview of the concept that we are
covering and then the practical hands-on
session and then there is a q a session
so you will be having this opportunity
to discuss uh with the mentor also what
is being covered and if there are any
questions but
in addition to that as i as was showing
you that asynchronous resources and
materials that we have so during the
week you will have to dedicate at least
three to four hours um
in the beginning
when we are starting the program to go
through some of those resources and then
you can reduce this time based on
your availability and having the
sessions and all of that but overall i
would say you'll have to take out five
to six hours or seven to eight hours
based on your expertise then level uh
for this training program per week
uh okay there is another question by
spandan so is this program manageable
with three with the three-month program
that we might have enrolled for already
so if you have already enrolled for a
three month program i'm not uh sure
which program you're mentioning but i
think we have participants who are
taking multiple programs and and it is
actually helping them to find some of
the problems if you're working as a
research fellow and if you want to do a
specific training on precision medicine
and if your
research proposal is on precision
medicine i think it will help you to
take the program to
take this program and directly work on
these case studies and problems which
are very specific to the topic that we
are covering so yes i think this will be
helpful and manageable if you have time
during the summer and if you can
attend the live sessions complete the
assignments i think it's manageable
all right so i think that you have
answered all the questions dr mohit
thank you for that and now i would like
to take all the participants here
through the program resources and also
other steps to register themselves on
the program page
so first of all i just like to introduce
myself i am sonali curry and the
community manager and i'm responsible
for the daily interaction with thousands
of users that are a part of a community
that is managed by fine powder
so uh for the different parts of the
sessions that dr mohit uh explained we
will leverage our mixed logic resources
that you can use to learn about
precision medicine we'll explore the
asynchronous coursework with theoretical
material quizzes and practical
assignments our cloud-based analytical
server where you can analyze large or
mixed data and
visualize results the omixlogic code
playground will uh help you practice
coding in r and python and as well as
repositories of project examples are
some of the things that we're going to
explore these methods which we discussed
will include hands-on exercises on the
tbi info platform which provides a
simple and intuitive user interface for
processing analyzing and machine
learning methods for multi-omics data
and throughout the course you will be
given the directions
to access the t-bioinfo platform for
bioinformatics processing and analysis
of rna-seq data
the platform includes demo pipelines as
well as data management and analysis
cloud infrastructure to run
bioinformatics pipelines
different stages of analysis are
performed in different sections in this
multi-omics platform
and behind many of the methods are
scripts written in popular coding
languages such as r and python and these
are also explained in tutorials that you
will access to from uh by being a part
of this precision medicine program so
from visualization of genomic data to
exploratory analysis and hypothesis
testing
at the end of the program participants
will receive the certification of
participation and also registering for
the program now you will get the access
to the limited scholarship seats that we
have that would enable up to 50 off on
the program registration i will shortly
take you through the program page and
explain uh the steps to register
yourself for the program
also i will take you through our social
media handles which you can join and
become a part of our bioinformatics
community in these social media handles
we keep sharing about recent trends in
research training material to learn and
get hands-on practical skills for these
trends updates about omix logic learn
portal and also the tea bioinfo server
also we share job posts for those who
complete the omixlogic training and are
ready to apply their knowledge to
resolve the real world problems
so i'll just quickly go to the amic
subject learn portal now and take you
all through the program page and let you
know how you can register yourself
for the program
so once again we are back on the
omnislogic learn portal the link is in
the
chat
yes now please make sure that you have
signed up already and have an account as
she got explained and have uh updated
your profile
now let's go directly to the program
page and see how you can register
yourself for the program
so on the program page you will find all
the information if you have any
questions uh still if if you still have
any questions about any of the topics
that would be covered you can go through
the same papers here on the program page
and if you install a little bit more you
will find three different levels which
are beginner intermediate and advanced
these levels are actually referred to
the number of days that the participant
will have an access to so in the
beginner level you are going to have the
access to the program for 45 days and in
the intermediate level you have an
access to the program for 16 days where
you will also be able to come up with a
research proposal that you can further
work on in the research fellowship
program and in the advanced level you
will get the access for 90 days where
you can work on your research project as
well along with the precision medicine
training so that is the difference
between beginner intermediate and
advanced level and also in the
intermediate and advanced level you will
get the access to a one-on-one expert
sessions and 24 7 mentor support in the
advanced level you also have an option
for certificate of excellence as you
also be a part of the research
fellowship program
now it's up to you how for how many days
you want to enroll for the program and
it's very simple to register yourself we
just need to click on the select option
button for whichever subscription level
you would like to enroll yourself for
and then just proceed uh with the
registration
[Music]
also uh here on the program page itself
we have listed some program courses and
project libraries that you will have an
access to as a part of this pro
program and also you are supposed to go
through these resources so as dr muvik
explained that we have a bunch of
example projects that you will be going
through and learn from them about how
precision medicine could actually be
applied so these are the resources that
you can go through and learn from and
after a successful completion of the
program you will be
getting a certificate of completion and
also a certificate of excellence as a
part of the advanced level of
subscription that i already explained
now i want to share with you some of our
social media handles so that you can
stay updated with all the updates and
all the training programs that we would
be having and also be updated about a
job post that we keep on posting on our
social media handles so our presence is
there on youtube i'll share the link in
the chat as well
and do join our community on youtube so
that you stay connected with us uh and
watch the videos that we keep posting
about different uh types of
specialization tracks and also the
training programs and then we are also
there on facebook by the name of buying
biotech so you can follow us on facebook
as well if you are there and uh now
comes the very important groups on
linkedin
so i'll just share the group of linkedin
channel as well in the
chat box
so we have a page on linkedin by the
name of omixlogic and we also have a
group where we have experts as well and
we keep on posting about the updates and
also the resources that you that you can
leverage from
this is the
page that is comics logic for which i
have shared the link in the chat
and the group's name on linkedin for
omixlogic is machine learning biomedical
data mining and high throughput data
analysis
so you're most welcome to join our bio
informatics community community and
leverage the resources and also the
experts who are a part of a community
so that was all that i wanted to discuss
with all of you today and i see we have
a question that special already answered
that's great so do we have any other
questions please you can put them in the
chat box
[Music]
so like i don't see any more questions
and i'd like to thank everyone for
joining today's session we will also be
sharing the session video recording all
right so if we
yes sir so if you have no more questions
i think we can end the session and uh
before we end today's session i just
like to put our email address that is
marketing at it on soldier.com please
feel free to reach out to us uh for any
questions and we'll be happy to help and
uh while introducing if you face any any
uh technical issue please feel free to
reach out to spa she will help you
become a part of the program and get
started with your training and research
in precision medicine
next we'll be meeting on june 14th so
thank you everyone for joining we'll
catch up on june 14th when the program
begins